Prime Time ratings last night CNN 569
000 Fox News 1.73 million okay MSNBC
1.86 million the first episode of Tucker
Carlson on Twitter 82 million in 20
hours so far
so basically an adx increase over what
would be considered traditional
mainstream media yeah of 40 30X over all
three put together yeah
well
um
where do you get your news from Mostly
the internet
how do you select your source and how do
you bounce you know
we're in an interesting time a time
where I think people have more access to
information than in the history of
humankind and it seems like every day
where through that envelope or threshold
even more
I have seen it in myself I've seen it
other people I'm sure you have too
the pros of the internet is you can find
anything you want to the cons of the
internet is you can find anything that
you want to if you go there pre-cocked
or with some type of confirmation bias
let me just tell anybody what they're
going to find on the internet exactly
what they're looking for
and you can get lost in fake news
literally like satire sites that
sometimes are so ridiculously good
they're hard to tell that they're satire
[__] totally here for it
um you'll come on to traditional media
Outlets like in the Fox News the CNN and
if I'm sorry if this day and age if
people don't realize that everybody and
that message is bought and paid for I
don't know how to help you because it's
right there in your face you'd have to
be blind and not see it and I don't have
a problem with people getting news from
either one of those sources let's just
recognize there's a slant on it and a
bias and also they're in the business of
selling ads just like TV
so it leads you at this place
where do you get information do you go
into sub stack do you go on to Twitter
do you go on to traditional media
Outlets how much do you have to balance
it against the other side to determine
that the information that you're getting
is actually legitimate or real did you
see the debate between Malcolm Gladwell
and Douglas Murray a couple of months
ago no you know Malcolm and Douglas as
well yeah and uh it was a discussion
around mainstream media basically needs
to it it's not something that you should
be able to trust and there was some
really interesting arguments from both
sides that there are constrictions and
guidelines around what you can and can't
do with traditional media that are
unrestricted when it comes to the more
New Media but that also brings with it
degrees of freedom that people can take
advantage of you have a really really
interesting discussion and I think the
sort of terminally online World sees New
Media as this Bastion of free speech
which gets itself closer to the truth
because it's no longer encumbered by any
of the rules and procedures and the
bought and paid for and so on
but I think if everybody took a really
close look at it the incentives are
different but they're still not exactly
pure free speech and Truth are not
always synonymous and I think people
have to be really cautious with that I
don't have a great answer for myself as
to where you even bounce
ideas or resources
especially in a world where
like I've just recently started playing
around with chat GPT holy [__] or Image
Creators holy [__] and these are in the
in like what will be viewed in the very
near future as their infancy if they're
that good right now
and it can really fool intelligent
people
I feel like
Skynet is just around the corner
we are
mere inches away from just getting butt
[__] by robots that's what it's going
to look like
dude I I have a I have a friend who
sells silk pillowcases and bamboo sheets
on Amazon
and he has been Amazon funneling and
building his business open so on and so
forth it's very effortful to do and he
got chat GPT to write his sales page for
him and then he used mid-journey to
create the photos that he needed to do
for the image listing and the increase
in his sales that he's had is absolutely
absurd and he showed me look these are
the other top five competitors for
bamboo sheets and silk pillowcases in
the United States and look at how much
better my images are he's like well
because I wasn't constrained by reality
or physics I was able to just
perfectly dial in exactly what I wanted
through mid-journey and I got chat GPT
to write the prompts for mid-journey so
you've got AIS telling AIS what to do so
I literally
the day before yesterday this is the 7th
of June I think on the 5th of June I
tried mid-journey for the first time
because I kept seeing articles about it
and I was thinking
how could I make I'm like could I
improve YouTube thumbnails for the
podcast messing around with this because
oftentimes as I'm sure you were your
staff knows I kind of want to have a
certain feel so I'll just Google image
search
image search [__] I'm going to create it
in a day and a half and I'm going to be
super upfront honest I'm an idiot I am
not an intelligent person I can like I
can Wrecking Ball my way through life in
a day and a half I have already created
some images that were beyond what I was
even thinking was possible
and that's 1.5 days
I mean with the least experienced user
on the planet yeah
yeah it's terrifying man so I think your
point when it comes to talking about
media heterodox New Wave whatever uh is
that you're going to be able to
propagate a lot more news stories that
are going to be automatically generated
maybe this is the bulk of reporting the
boring stuff that just needs to be done
potentially will come from chat GPT or
some of the sort of automated system
which has been trained on the biases
that humans have so it perpetuates and
propagates those existing biases so yeah
man this this Tucker thing is is
absolutely fascinating you know for I
think uh Matt Walsh is what is a woman
that the daily wire released over the
weekend to celebrate the start of pride
month that's right they released it
their Twitter allowed him to put it up
correct then Elon Musk retweeted it and
pinned it that is potentially the most
viewed documentary in human history now
because it got hundreds of million I
think 100 million plays over the weekend
that's insane on Twitter the most viewed
documentary in human history I think
that's a metric for how much people
don't have faith anymore in traditional
media sources I truly think that it is
my concern is
with the AI
whether it's a good thing or bad thing
at some point
my thoughts will always shift back to
weaponization
and the volume of information that that
AI can create and could get the snowball
rolling downhill before people could
actually backtrack and figure it out for
most people it seems like they're
they're deeply held beliefs or about one
click deep and it's usually the first
search result so if you cut a volume of
information heading in the wrong
direction that was legitimately untrue
and I think it's a very uh fair thing to
say that the the Western World however
you would want to Define that has you
know there's an access to every belief
system and there's an access to those
belief systems and those belief systems
are also looking at Ai and leveraging Ai
and weaponing weaponizing AI I don't
know if we're intelligent enough as a
species to survive well think about it
this way right you make content on the
internet as do I
what you're trying to do is find a
balance somewhere between exactly what
you want to talk about and what your
interests are and some degree of what's
going to be at least partially
interesting to the audience you don't
want to compromise yourself so much that
you get audience captured but you don't
want to be so nichy and completely
solipsistic that all you do is indulge
yourself over and over it's a blend
between the two right there is a third
participant in every conversation that
is the audience member that's listening
what you're trying to do is in some
regard on varying degrees reverse
engineer what the audience wants right
that's at least you're conscious of what
the audience wants so creators try to do
that and then algorithms try to deliver
content that people want to it so the
Creator predicts what the algorithm
needs based on what the audience wants
now you can remove the Creator
altogether and just go algorithm direct
to Consumer right because you have no
restriction on how many different
iterations of content and images you
remember the Cambridge analytica thing
right where yes there was
um custom built memes around the exact
pain point that these particular
subgroups had around Hillary Clinton or
whoever it was and we're going to Target
them and create them and do all of the
rest of them but there's still a guy
somewhere sat working out what meme to
make what text to use dragging the image
in creating it putting it out there you
could have individual me right I know
Andy's profile and we will make a meme
or a series of memes just for him so I
think yeah but wait until the AI can
replace that individual and then you
have ai teaching other AI correct
correct and then we have to go beg a
robot for our water ration every day
yeah well dude
I think it's terrifying yeah it is and
when you think that within the space of
probably
three years it wouldn't be surprising if
most of the content created on the
Internet is no longer human generated if
you think that the internet is
accessible at the moment
at least you know the content that
you're consuming was made by another
person
yeah in the future it very well might be
the case that it's a rarity to not have
an automated oh my God this is a post
from a real person as opposed to an
automated uh bot of some kind there's
already
um
social media where you need to upload
images of your face I think maybe even
Instagram has this for verification now
to ensure that it's not bots so you have
to put a photo of your face up and maybe
a photo of your idea and what this does
is it ensures not only is it the same
person but if you try and duplicate it
you can't have more than one account or
some other some such which is trying to
restrict bot activity and that's just
now
I mean in one and a half days on
mid-journey I feel like I could create
both of those things full Universe give
me a half an hour and I could create
both of those things and then you have a
person I mean what is it what happens
when it gets to the point if we're not
already edging towards it already where
people are questioning every piece of
information that comes at them because
they don't know they don't know if it's
biased I think we're already done I
think we're already there too but I
don't know if I don't think we're
trending for it to get better
I'm concerned that we're trending for it
to get worse and where does that land us
where do people go at that point to
actually get information about the world
that they can trust what you you
mentioned at the beginning that
the issue that people have is now an
abundance not scarcity right there's too
much information not too little
information and very quickly the over
the last sort of 30 years
the skill set that was most advantageous
to a human went from someone who was
able to seek out information to somebody
that is able to discern information
right it's now all about can you work
out how legitimate this is can you do
your sources or your checks a video from
a friend of mine went hyper viral as he
was talking about
um America is the third highest country
out of 193 Nations worldwide in gun
crime and if you were to remove the five
largest cities for gun crime from that
we would move from third down to 190th
or 189th or something like that it took
me one Google search to find out that
that's not true that's not even remote
it sounds [__] amazing yeah like oh
[__] let's just cut these cities out of
the U.S problem solved oh and there was
like a little bit of a they're mostly
blue cities and blah blah blah and don't
get me wrong dude if I'd heard it and
I've propagated tons and tons of stuff
like that I heard this like little
Zinger let me get it out there that
sounds cool uh but yeah that's you with
your human biases imagine if you had a
custom purpose-built viral machine that
knew exactly the way to deliver it that
knew exactly what was going to trigger
you but going back to the Tucker
conversation right
you as somebody that's been in this
great nation longer than I have
How likely do you think it is that more
and more of the news guys I think Trevor
Noah recently left his show I think he
was released or maybe left uh took a
Carlson obviously released by Fox Now
doing his own thing
what do you think the future of these
sorts of news organizations would be if
people can go and make 40 times the
entire Prime Time ratings by going in
and yoloing it themselves with a couple
of students in a nice garage setup in
the house
maybe we don't need mainstream meter
anymore I think we're through the
Looking Glass on that one I I think that
Tucker and just those numbers alone
speak to
how much people are looking to a
traditional source and the traditional
models I mean I think they're mired in
bureaucracy I have been to the Fox News
Studio a few times I've done a couple of
written pieces for them and a couple of
uh in-person stuff and it is a large
building with a massive amount of people
that is constrained you know they have
they do have different uh journalistic
uh thresholds and barriers that they're
going to need to at least be able to
clear to present uh information and
ideas but they're way slower and there
are 100 soft and probably hard
boundaries on what their hosts can say
what they can do and I'm sure that the
money is good I have no idea what they
what they make but if somebody wants to
go out and have complete flexibility and
autonomy and probably actually make
orders of magnitude more money by being
on their own why would you admire
yourself in bureaucracy when you can put
together a small team and be you know
the first person through the door and
then reap the benefit of that are you on
a network your show uh no just the
internet no but you you know what you
know what I mean like an iHeartRadio uh
no I put it up on the just the normal
any sponsors that you do you handle
yourself either through an agency that's
working like as a consultant for you uh
I used to go through the agency route
and then just due to my relationship
with evident Black Rifle I just
streamlined it and was like you know
what how about we just do this so my
point being that even within our world
the New Media thing there are varying
degrees of people being bought now if it
comes to uh networks and stuff like that
the people that are listening are
concerned my favorite creators on
iHeartRadio maybe they're part of a
global conspiracy those guys they help
with production they help you get guests
and they sell ads right like they're not
they're not really it increases yeah it
increases your reach largely in the
experience I do have with those things
there are other platforms and maybe
those platforms whatever they fall into
whatever uh the globalist or whatever it
might be that doesn't mean you as
somebody who has content on that
platform is a part of that correct yeah
my point being that even within that you
found it easier to streamline even what
is already quite a streamlined way of
working so for somebody like took it I
would be really interested to know
why Twitter apart from the fact that you
can reach what will probably hit 100
million plays in 24 hours which there's
no way even on YouTube that you could do
that if you did 100 million plays on
YouTube in 24 hours you'll be the number
one trending video worldwide on that
side
Mr BEAST's squid game video did
somewhere in the region of 70 million
but that was a movie level production
that was custom built for virality
Tucker just I mean it was a well-crafted
monologue he was actually talking about
this um Dam explosion
have you seen this so uh Tucker points
to kiev's uh possible role in the
kakovka damburst so if it was
intentional it was not a military tactic
it was an act of terrorism Tucker said
commenting on the incident blowing up
the dam may be bad for Ukraine but it
hurts Russia more and for precisely that
reason the Ukrainian government has
considered destroying it so basically
he's saying maybe this is a false flaggy
type thing yeah
the water level below this Dam has risen
by 12 meters which that's going to
change some neighborhood layouts [__]
city
um that's what used to be a city yeah
correct correct you're now your granny's
now at the bottom of a leg totally um
but my point being that he's able to
talk about stuff that he wants yeah
without any restriction I don't know how
he's monetizing and I would love to know
why he chose Twitter apart from reach
reach is self-evident is he being paid
there's no ads as far as I can see I do
play for Twitter blue which means maybe
I'm ad-free so perhaps there would have
been pre-roll ads running before it
maybe people that have watched it that
don't pay for Twitter blue can tell us
or whatever if they saw Rad but you
didn't do a this episode is brought to
you by yeah anything there was no ads
Running part way through it could lead
to that I mean I don't I don't know a
whole lot about Tucker in the world that
he comes from I'm gonna assume he was
well taken care of when he was at Fox so
the move
might actually be to drive awareness
before the monetization can you imagine
the hammer you could swing in
negotiation be like oh hey by the way I
do about 100 billion plays in 24 hours
so here's my rate oh you don't like my
rate next yeah dude so again for the
people that don't know this world I
would guess you could probably charge
between a 10 and a 20 CPM on that so
that's per thousand plays which is a
[__] ungodly yeah amount of money
let's just multiply that by a number
that has a lot of zeros yeah correct and
you know it doesn't matter how much
token was being paid at Fox yeah I can
guarantee it wasn't that much nobody
nobody [__] talks no sorts of numbers
but I don't think he's in a rush to
monetize no no I think his move is
probably
build accumulate build Foundation
because then you can take it then you're
the you're the captain of your own ship
you have your hand on the wheel and
people can get on board but you get to
tell them what stateroom they're in as
opposed to the other way around yes and
think about it this way Tom Segura that
does your mom's house he pivoted from
comedian comedian with podcasts comedian
with very well produced podcast comedian
with podcast and other podcasts under it
to now Network yeah so he is vertically
integrating himself further and further
back up the chain smart yeah and you
know I don't know who runs who directs
the editorial policy at Fox News
something tells me that I've never seen
them on TV and I don't respect them as a
Creator oh they're not a Creator I bet
you it's a lawyer probably yeah but I
respect Tom Segura as a Creator I know
that he understands the craft so I go oh
yeah that that network has legitimacy
and Tucker Carlson will be able to lend
legitimacy to other people that come
along it's the same with uh Ben Shapiro
on The Daily Wire yeah right you know
Shapiro Jeremy boring Jeremy not
necessarily front-facing but no he can
he's done well crafted adverts and I've
seen him on cousin he can speak and you
know in a world of
uh social media where people want that
behind the scenes thing they want to
know Kim Kardashian's dog's name and
they want to know where Zac Efron goes
for coffee on blah blah and his
Instagram stories I think that that's I
think that gives a degree of resonance
yeah I'll be curious to see what he does
with it I mean what I guess the better
metric will be how does the second video
do
well if the algorithm's anything to go
by that would be what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace